[Musique]
j'ai deux problèmes avec vous soit vous
n'écoutez rien soit vous ne comprenez
rien c'est fini
donc oui nous attendait c'est dire si
fabre voix pour la fête la diarrhée
verbale et kate des sanctions dures mais
le corps et vous les on est sur des
procédures qui dure 10 croyez qu'avec la
carrière qui est la mienne
je comprends en fait porte-parole et
donc porter une parole compliqué et
débile c'est pas facile et moi mais
j'aime qu'on voit quelque chose c'est
que monsieur est un homme de spectacle
oui jamais rien d'autre en fait je vous
en prie d'être avec nous oui non pas
très fébrile y'at-il de meilleurs
intervenants de l'année fabrice est ce
que vous avez été heureux d'intervenants
dans cette émission
oui c'est vrai en fait je réfléchissais
en ont à la suite de notre interview
donc 11,6 un petit peu à ce que parce
qu'ils étaient les missions et en fait
je crois que j'ai une comparaison qui
est peut-être là la meilleure je pense
possible en fait cette émission est à la
télé ce que le baroque est architecture
alors pour celles film peut penser que
c'est le meilleur acteur britannique
moi personnellement je le pense oui
fabrice je pense voilà vous êtes là je
vraiment la révélation de l'année
oui parce que pour moi il ya le fond et
la forme vous faites du spectacle et en
même temps vous apporter de réelles
informations et vous avez pu éclairer
les français qui regardent l'émission
pendant cette période compliquée parce
que malgré tous vos avis toujours beau
dossier et vos sources sont sûres donc
merci nous avoir éclairé
alors on va prendre de huy est de nos
jours nous voilà prêts moutot si pour
toi c'est de moi j'aimerais bien les
mêmes j'ai bien aimé tout ce qu'il a
dégagé la personnalité à chaque fois
qu'on s'est mis en face de lui il a posé
des questions à des gens les gens
disaient ils ont bégayé n'étaient pas
prêts ils annulent qui était pas mouillé
à chaque télé un romillon place
yvinec des dossiers des épi et puis
parfois c'était vrai on allait voir sur
internet on rompt vérifier c'était vrai
quand il sort et qui va voir gilles et
qui dit c'est qui lui - sam j'étais
devant ma télé j'étais plié de rire une
storia star j'ai rarement j'ai filmé des
gens dans ma télé pour faire un sens
pour moi
pour moi ça a été la révélation j'adore
et je suis pas obligé de venir manger
des chevaux chargés de médias j'adore
moi j'adore tous ces mecs là idée me
fait rire un pour moi il a toutes les
qualités requises
de la télévision télévisuellement
parlant il a le physique
il a les lunettes il a le la le manteau
et il a tout ce qu'il faut et
franchement ça fait du bien enfin
d'avoir quelqu'un qui n'est pas langue
de bois mais jusqu'au bout et qui assume
totalement ses prises de position et il
est calé sur son sujet et comme l'a dit
raymond quand il a une personne en face
une personne qui est censé être mieux
qu'à une chute lui de haut niveau des
connaissances et bien c'est mieux que
tout le monde
il le prend il le prouve donc je trouve
ça génial la lie à la cdu bon il ya
envie d'aller revoir qu'il verdez après
delà de son humour et de sa répartie l'a
prouvé que toutes les personnes qui ont
une pensée à l'encontre de celle qui est
véhiculée par le gouvernement ne sont
pas que des fous et que des complotistes
c'est aussi celle qui réfléchissent et
qu'ils nous font réfléchir je trouve
qu'il nous a fait beaucoup réfléchir
nous a posé des questions et nous a
éclairés sur le coville donc bravo
fabrice et l'a fait du bien au fait
plaisir face et philosophiques
oui oui forcément après ça j'aurais
oserais je vous dire que je m'en fous un
peu way berne est certainement sur
pattes heures doublée danger public
ramené sur ce plateau des dossiers
répondent aux autres en fait c'est
marrant je prends je savais que vous
allez dire ça et donc du coup ça m'a
permis je triche un peu préparé ma
réplique est en réalité je savais que
vous alliez dire que j'étais dangereux
c'est pourquoi je le savais parce que
tout le monde l'a dit si je fais
réfléchir et je comprends que quelqu'un
comme dit quelqu'un qu'il fasse
réfléchir ça paraisse dangereux en fait
parce que vous êtes tellement
insignifiant mais je le dis très
calmement et avec beaucoup beaucoup de
respect beaucoup effectivement de ce
festival mais tranquillité jamais on
sait jamais avec vous quelle est la part
de vérité quelle est la part de china
pas un dossier pourri du texas à monter
cette fois j'avais alors cette fois je
n'ai pas de dossiers mais j'ai des
cadeaux non non et des cadeaux pour tous
les gamins cette année alors allez-y
alors que deux reprises vidéo pour cette
dernière c'est manu fabrice bercy alors
j'ai des bons cadeaux pour les fêtes
s'avèrent cadeau pour moi un génial la
boucle de ceinture elle est magnifique
et les basses est maintenu m me conte
médiéval et mercy corps save her is et
la tenue de compte tu vas l'année j'ai
un cadeau pour tout le monde va aller où
ces prêts dont c'est bien merci fabrice
j'ai tout petits chevaux géo pas votre a
pensé à moi pendant l'été pourquoi le
cheval à cheval
j'ai appris un truc vous voyez si un
endroit où je m'énerve jamais ch panne
mais jamais je l'avais gardé parce qu'au
fond convaincre plus que contraindre ou
c'est ça la clé à cheval nan alors
évidemment après ça marche si le cheval
est un peu intelligent quoi c'est que si
je ne suis pas arrivé à convaincre
puisque contre un avec certains d'entre
vous c'est ça le problème est donc mois
après que vous disiez je suis un danger
si vous voulez j'ai voulu dire
franchement je m'en fous complètement
en fait pas plus que les compliments ne
me ne me touche finalement plus que ça
c'est sympa et je vous remercie
finalement ce que vous pensez de moi
c'est peut-être la grande particularité
je m'en fous dire que moi je suis venu
ici parce qu'on m'a invité et la parole
que je porte à n'est pas la mienne on me
demandait des débats très bien je fais
ce que je sais faire je débats et c'est
précisément ce que vous ne savez pas
faire c'est ça qui est dommage en fait
c'est comme s'il avait pas de déballage
et
non mais c'est un peu vrai parce que
quand vous arrivez en disant que je suis
un danger mais finalement c'est pas du
débat ça c'est de la tène il s'en fou de
dire et c'est fini ce temps là il est
fini ce temps du spectacle ce temps où
effectivement on vient traiter les gens
de complotiste de danger et ne vous
avais pas compris que les français en
ont marre vous faites que ça fait un an
et demi maintenant qu'on les bassines
avec des caricatures et en fait ce que
vous êtes c'est ça le problème au fond
vous êtes une caricature et c'est
précisément ce que j'essayais de ne pas
vous êtes une girouette la girouette du
paf vous avez évolué en fonction des
événements là où était votre intérêt à
retourner faire du qatar du canasson et
foutez nous la paix mon propos est
exactement là c'est à dire que
l'insultent c'est toujours l'argument du
pauvre c'est à dire que c'est celui qui
n'a plus rien là qui se retrouvent à
dire aller faire du canasson m'est cher
monsieur vous devriez en faire du
canasson comme vous dites ça vous
apprendrai plein de choses mais
tellement chose parce qu'à cheval
figurez vous il faut le calme du moine
l'autorité du maître mais la bienvenue
vous n'avez pas à votre égard
contrairement à vous j'ai une
bienveillance j'ai effectivement une
autorité qui est celle de ma
connaissance est bon évidemment après ce
qui va mal mais non un peu non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi j'ai pas le melon
je suis qu'un borg au royaume des
aveugles les banques sont voilà c'est
tout en fait que voulez vous je vous
dise
hier vous venez pour cette dernière
faire le show faites le si ça vous amuse
mon dieu faites le mais regardez par
exemple pendant que vous parlez la f10
américaine hier une révélation vient
d'expliquer les effets secondaires des
vaccins sur les jeunes et en particulier
les myocardite infectieuses dont je
parlais ici ça a explosé leurs attentes
au point de l'allemagne est finalement
bien pour la vaccination des ados de
dire qu'il ne faut vacciner que les ados
qui ont eu des très graves problèmes de
santé
donc quand je vous disais que la
vaccination des ados été une folie et
que vous me repreniez sur ce point
encore une fois vous parliez sans savoir
et encore une fois la différence c'est
que je savais parce que moi
effectivement je ne nie pas la gazette
sportive
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas je vous inviterai très
souvent alors je viendrai merci fabrice
et vous savez qu'on s'apprécie beaucoup
fabrice éboue danse aimerait mieux après
un beau cadeau d'ailleurs comme il ya eu
un truc je suis d'accord il ya un truc
entre nous c'est vrai oui on va parler
on sait bien qu'ils aiment bien venir
j'adore quand il vient en tout cas merci
abu dhabi et bravo
[Applaudissements]
l'ebit site
merci merci vous avez vu comme ils les
sports et les sports bravo chine passait
pour cent restants mais je sais ce que
je disais et les sports il ya gazettes
sportives jusque là tout va bien quoi
dire qu'à un moment si vous voulez c'est
sage tout pour terminer là dessus en
fait il ya juste un détail que personne
forte il faut toujours y compris en fait
moi je suis venu ici exactement comme je
suis et ça c'est à dire qu'en fait je
conçois mes nerfs je m'énerve quand ça
m'énerve en fait on parlait du baroque
c'est sa particularité
le barreau qui casse les codes on est
effectivement une exubérance on est sur
quelque chose qui est inattendue dans le
baroque et ben en fait moi c'est ce que
je suis maroc
ben c'est ça merci c'est tout
[Applaudissements]